it's backfiring activism that is a
subject of tonight's waters words
hardcore Democratic activists are
threatening to overwhelm the rest of the
party they disrupt peaceful events make
threats and cause violence this week we
saw a teenager attacked for wearing a
make America great again hat that teens
going to join me later for an exclusive
interview on July 4th in lower Manhattan
Americans were sightseeing with their
families celebrating our independence
and preparing to watch the fireworks
suddenly a radical African immigrant
activists began scaling the Statue of
Liberty the woman part of the Trump
resistance movement refused to come down
police and firemen were deployed the
entire Liberty Island filled with 4,000
tourists was evacuated the statue was
closed 3,000 visitors were turned away
on the monuments busiest day of the year
because one selfish individual didn't
agree with President Trump's immigration
policy and after a four-hour standoff
she was arrested
Teresa como born in the Congo was
slapped with a few misdemeanor charges
she's probably not even gonna spend the
day in jail now after costing the city
tax dollars and man-hours diverting
valuable police resources from fighting
real crime and ruining thousands of
Americans visit to the Statue of Liberty
on July 4th president Trump weighed in
at a rally earlier in Montana you saw
that clown yesterday on the Statue of
Liberty I would have said let's get some
Nets and let's wait till she comes to
just get some nets really this
self-centered stun artist has a wacky
past she's filed several seemingly
frivolous racial discrimination lawsuits
against various entities she had run-ins
with neighbors
she's been slapped with nearly five
thousand dollars in fines by the
Department of Sanitation she's also been
arrested for trespassing and assaulting
a police officer and following her
release from jail this week
okoma said she was inspired by Michelle
Obama Michelle Obama
our beloved first lady that I care so
much about say when they go low we go
high and I went as high as I could back
this country apart nothing you can say
to me will justify putting children in
cages only a stupid on intelligent
coward and insecure I would at a mania
with with a tender age child from its
mother first of all I don't think
Michelle Obama wants your endorsement
second the photo of a child in a cage
that image she's talking about was from
2014 the Obama administration did that
Trump didn't put that kid in the cage
fake news is now causing real rage we
all want families to stay together so
let's all work together to achieve that
goal while at the same time protecting
our border and protecting children from
fake parent human smugglers and radical
Democratic toughest tactics have turned
regular Americans against their party
and their cause you'll remember black
lives matter protesters disrupted the
Macy's Thanksgiving Day Parade while
parents were celebrating the holiday
with their young kids Occupy Wall Street
protesters who wanted higher income for
workers shut down traffic in Detroit so
people couldn't commute to work on time
and earn their income left wingers who
were screaming about Trump's rhetoric on
Muslims and immigrants caused mayhem
during his inauguration and fire bombed
a limo owned by a Muslim immigrant
idiots Democrats protested a nice raid
in Oakland ice is not welcome in this
country HSI is not welcoming we're gonna
fight back we're not gonna let people
just disappear like this turns out ice
was conducting a raid on human sex
traffickers Democrats actually rallied
against this you can't make this stuff
up so after the family separation
controversy
the border and all the recent street
action by Maxine Waters is left winters
Trump's approval rating is up with
Hispanics it's up 10 points this
according to a Harvard Harris poll
released just a few days ago amazing
isn't it and now the most important
issue determining people's votes in the
midterms immigration largely driven by
Republican enthusiasm so Democrats your
radical tactics are backfiring be
careful what you wish for